صراعه في السودان في شهره الثاني خريطه
المواجهه تتسع وتتسع معها معاناه
السودانيين مقاتله الجيش شنت هجمات على
ضواحي العاصمه الخرطوم وجنوب ام درمان
اضافه الى شمالي الخرطوم بحري ووقعت
اشتباكات ايضا في منطقه شارع النيل وسط
الخرطوم وفي اقليم دارفور كانت مدينه يالا
عاصمه ولايه جنوب دارفور مسرحا لمواجهه
عسكريه ومعارك داميه في المدينه حيث اندلع
قتال بري هناك قوه الجيش اعلنت سيطرتها
على المدينه بعد اشتباكات مع قوات الدعم
السريع واستهداف حاميه النيال العسكريه
كما شهدت مدينه زلنجي في ولايه وسط دارفور
اشتباكات مسلحه بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش وبينما يدخل الصراع اسبوعه السادس
تحصي البلاد قتلاها فبحسب نقابه الاطباء
السودانيين تجاوز عدد القتل 850 شخصا
مدنيا فيما اكثر من
4390 شخصا حصيله الضحايا قد تكون اعلى
بكثير وفق اطباء خصوصا في ظل صعوبه الوصول
الى جميع المستشفيات تحديدا خارج العاصمه
لحصر جميع الوفيات او الاصابات بدقه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات